this video is kindly sponsored by
morningbro
the free daily newsletter hey 42 here
if you ever find yourself in the seaside
town of hartlepool
in the northeast of england head to the
harbour and look for the monkey statue
you'll know him by his rather
cross-looking
face as he sits on his plinth arms and
legs curled around a bowl
with a sign that reads make a wish for
the monkey
inviting people to throw a coin in and
this monkey has every right to feel a
little cross
because he was apparently hanged
by a bunch of heartly pearl fishermen
back in the early 19th century
now it's no secret our ancestors loved a
good hanging
with public executions carried out in
britain right up until
1868 even for relatively innocuous
crimes like
minor burglaries or forging banknotes
but no one's ever caught a monkey
forging a banknote
let alone anything worse so
why would anyone want to hang one
britain in the early 19th century was it
war
not with the monkeys of course that
would be mental
but with napoleon's france
the napoleonic wars were a series of
bloody conflicts fought between 1803
and 1815 as napoleon sought to expand
his empire
and britain was high on his list of
places to invade
the wars threw the country into a state
of fear and chaos
with men signing up to fight and
government investing
heavily in new ships cannons and sea
defenses
you can still see large stone towers
known as martello towers
in seaside towns across southern england
built in anticipation of the need to
defend
a napoleonic invasion
all this was pretty expensive and so
taxes
shot up at the same time napoleon
stopped large numbers of trade ships
from traveling to britain leading to
food shortages and ever-increasing
prices
times were hard and it's fair to say
the french weren't overly popular
amongst britons at the time
all of which goes some way to explain
why when a french ship
got into trouble in stormy seas near
hartley pools harbour
instead of attempting to help the town's
fishermen simply
sat on the dock and kept watch for any
plucky survivors who might try and swim
their way to shore
apparently the fishermen fancied
themselves as potential war heroes
hoping to capture a french soldier
interrogate him
and perhaps even put an end to the war
by learning some
vital piece of intel that might help the
war effort
and they were it seemed in luck
because before long a frenchman did
indeed wash up on the hartley pool shore
the fisherman sprang into action grabbed
the sailor and dragged him onto the
beach
before morning brew i used to spend my
morning scrolling through various social
media
aimlessly looking for something to
stimulate my sleepy neurons
but i often found myself looking at the
same monotonous news as the day before
but now with morning brew i can be up to
date with all the latest business tech
and finance news
in just five minutes morning brew is
the perfect way to start your day
there's no den
sans tedious articles it's just relevant
informative updates written in a
refreshing
and witty narrative the newsletter is
delivered daily
from monday through to sunday meaning
you're reading new content
day to day just the other day on morning
brew i learned that wyoming
recently became the first u.s state to
officially recognize
a decentralized autonomous organization
that's a community that uses blockchain
to govern itself
without any central authority making it
the first
crypto friendly place to live in america
it's nice to see the earls west still
has its pioneer spirit
so if you're interested in business tech
or finance like i am
there's really no reason not to
subscribe to morning brew
it's completely free and it takes less
than 15 seconds
and to make it even easier you can just
go ahead and click the link in the
description below
to subscribe today when they got him
safely onto dry land
they were able to get a proper look at
him and
he turned out to be a strange sailor
indeed
being exceedingly hairy and surprisingly
small
but then the fishermen had never seen a
frenchman before
so perhaps they believed this was simply
what they looked like
after all british propaganda cartoons of
the time
depicted napoleon as being ridiculously
short and childlike he was drawn as a
tiny figure in boots that were far too
big for him
shaking his fist in a toddler-style
temper tantrum
or struggling with an enormous sword
that dwarfed his tiny body
of course the real napoleon wasn't small
at all
and at 5'7 stood several inches taller
than your average frenchman
in the early 19th century it was
pretty unsophisticated as far as
propaganda goes but
oddly enough the idea of a pint-sized
napoleon persists
even to this day the small hairy man was
also
chattering away unintelligibly but since
none of the fishermen spoke any
languages other than english
they probably assumed this monkey
chatter was what
french sounded like naturally the
language barrier made
questioning their spy rather difficult
the men drilled their captive with the
hardest hitting questions they could
think of
but instead of responding in english or
indeed
anything else that a civilized human
being might call a word
he kept making strange screeching noises
frustrated at their inability to gain
any war ending
information the fishermen put the
frenchman
on trial and convicted him of spying
he was then duly hanged in the town
square
using makeshift gallows made with wood
from his own
shipwreck just to really rub it in
[Applause]
[Music]
okay before we go any further i think
it's time to address the elephant in the
room
this all sounds a bit far-fetched
doesn't it i mean
the people of 19th century harley pool
weren't
the most enlightened around come to
think of it
the 21st century versions are much
better
but i'm guessing they were probably
capable of distinguishing
a man from a monkey and when you start
to dig a little deeper that isn't the
only part of this
hairy tail that starts to look a bit
suspect
for starters there's no records of a
french shipwreck near hartlepool at any
time during the napoleonic wars
fourteen ships did sink nearby during
those years
but none of them were french and whether
any of them had a monkey on board
is anyone's guess there's also no
mention of the story in any records from
around the time it supposedly happened
in fact the first mention of the hartley
pool monkey
comes in 1854 when a music hall
entertainer
named ned corvin began singing about it
ned wasn't a hartley pool man but a
geordie
raised around 25 miles away in newcastle
the son of a widow with four hungry
children to feed
ned needed to find a way to make some
cash quickly
and that he did becoming the northeast's
first big
music hall star travelling the region to
sing his songs to adoring
crowds but old ned wasn't even born
until
1830 15 years after the napoleonic wars
had finished
so how did he come across the monkey
story
and is there any chance that it might be
true
one theory is that the heartly pool
hanging incident
did indeed happen but the victim was a
boy
rather than a monkey at the time
warships employed young lads
to fetch gunpowder from a specialized
storage area within the ship
known as a powder magazine and
it just so happens that these boys were
known as
powder monkeys it's conceivable that it
wasn't a real monkey that washed ashore
in hartlepool
but a powder monkey and the meaning was
simply lost
during an intergenerational game of
chinese whispers
plausible but there's still a serious
problem that
as far as we know there were no
friendships wrecked near hartlepool
during the napoleonic wars
perhaps a more likely explanation for
the heartly poor monkey story
is that it grew out of a similar story
that originated in scotland
in 1772 and got rather out of hand
you see ned's song is very similar to a
tune
by the name of badamas hung the monkeyoh
which is about the hanging of a monkey
after a shipwreck
in the seaside village of badam in north
east scotland not only is the story
almost the same
the song has very similar lyrics to the
hartley pool song
and was even sung to the same tune
it's thought that ned corvin would
probably have toured scotland
and may have heard the song before
adapting it for hardly pool
even that doesn't quite cover it though
as it turns out that there are
bizarrely enough multiple stories and
songs about monkeys
being involved in cases of mistaken
identity
in the 19th century in one an irish
farmer goes to a barber shop for a shave
only to mistake a pet monkey for the
barber himself
in another very similar story that
emerged in newcastle
ned corvin's hometown a local labourer
mistakes a monkey
for a shopkeeper and another
newcastle-based story from around this
time
has a baboon running through the streets
dressed as a russian soldier
it seems likely that a combination of
all of these bizarre monkey tales
inspired ned corvin to write the heartly
pool monkey song
but why this weird proliferation of
songs and stories of monkeys being
mistaken for humans
in the first place well even all these
stories were based on real events
and our great great great grandparents
lived in some kind of
planet of the apes nightmare or
all of this monkey news was mostly just
a harmless way to
poke a bit of fun at people the
industrial town we now call hartley pool
was once known as west hartley pool
distinct from the original village of
hartley paul a little way up the coast
some think that corva may have written
the song for a west hartley pool
audience
so that his residents could feel
superior to the silly
yokels up the road in the old village it
was so stupid they couldn't tell a human
from a monkey
however it might have come about the
hartley pool monkey
has turned into an unlikely source of
pride for the town's people
inspiring a play and several
in 1999 the town's football club created
a new mascot
in honor of the hanged monkey named
hangus the monkey see what they did
there
honestly i could probably have done a
whole video on this one mascot
who seems to have courted more than his
fair share of controversy over the years
he's been kicked out of his own stadium
on more than one occasion
once on suspicion of being drunk another
time for pretending to have sex with a
female steward
real classy hangus and once for
sabotaging a charity tombola
hangus also once got into a friendly
fight with rival mascot desmond the
dragon
during which hangus proceeded to punch
the dragon's head
clean off i can only assume any young
fans watching at the time
carry the scars of that incident to this
day
in an absolutely epic plot twist the man
inside the monkey costume during all of
these
borderline illegal antics a chap called
stewart's drummond
somehow ended up becoming the mayor of
hartlepool
afterwards and seriously i'm not making
this up
campaigning on a promise of free bananas
for children
now i haven't exactly set him up as the
world's most reliable source
but drummond is absolutely adamant the
story of the hartley pillar monkey
the one that was hanged not the sex
offending mascot
is at least in part real claiming the
story is
so bizarre there simply must be some
element of truth to it
and perhaps he has a point many
hartlepodlians certainly feel
pretty committed to the story as
demonstrated in 2005 when an apparent
monkey bone washed up on the hartley
pool shore
causing huge excitement sadly
rather than proving the truth of this
tall tale it turned out to be
a prehistoric deer bone
whilst hartlepool's people have grown
quite attached to their monkey story
the same can't be said for the people of
bottom where what may have been the
original hanged monkey story
arose in fact it's still a sore point
now 200 years on so
if you ever find yourself in that
particular corner of aberdeenshire
trust me don't mention the monkey i
mentioned it once
but i think i got away with it all right
in their version of the story
a ship called the annie was wrecked just
off the coast of bottom
the law at the time stipulated that a
wreck was fair game
and local people could strip it of
anything they liked
as long as there was no one still living
on board
in fact many small communities relied on
shipwrecks for firewood
cargo and the odd bit of treasure to the
extent
that when lighthouses became commonplace
in the 19th century
there were protests because the locals
didn't want to lose their regular
shipwrecks
and the chance to plunder them
and so as would have been customary
when the annie was wrecked local
fishermen climbed on board
intending to strip the wreck of anything
they could use
they didn't find any men alive but
they did find a monkey whom they
promptly
hanged in some versions of the story the
fishermen did this because they thought
the monkey
would count as a living person or they
believed he was a living person
rather than a monkey meaning they
couldn't strip
the wreck in other versions it said they
thought the monkey was harboring the
soul of the devil
either way the outcome was the same the
devil monkey guthrop was coming to him
in the form of a short sharp drop
the story has been used to torment the
people of bottom
ever since it also fueled a bitter
rivalry between bottom
and nearby bernhaven burn haveners were
said to look down on bottomers
as backwards monkey hangers while
bottomers responded in kind by viewing
their neighbours
as idiots for continuing to believe such
a ridiculous story
so is this version of the monkey story
at least true
it's certainly the case that there was a
ship called the annie that was wrecked
off the coast of bottom
in 1772 but
that's where the verifiable truth of the
matter
seems to end no one knows why or how the
monkey got
involved and whilst there's no evidence
it didn't happen
there's no evidence it did either but
what we do know for sure
is that bottoms people dislike the song
intensely
even 200 years on and emphatically do
not want to be seen as callous monkey
murderers
i think we can all relate to that
perhaps the people
of hartlepool once felt the same about
their monkey story too
but i for one i'm glad they didn't try
to sweep it under the carpet
and now tell it with pride tall as this
tale may be
it offers a fascinating glimpse into how
stories can
catch the imagination be told and retold
over the generations
and how the most unlikely things can be
believed
even centuries later
thanks for watching check out my new
podcast
random interesting facts available on
youtube spotify
apple podcast and anywhere else you get
your podcasts
link in the description below thanks